[Música]
cuatro indicadores clave para medir el
cambio climático alcanzaron niveles
récord en 2021 según lo alertó hoy
miércoles un nuevo informe de la
organización meteorológica mundial lado
m/m señaló que los datos son un nuevo
ejemplo de que las actividades humanas
están provocando cambios a escala
planetaria el océano y también la
atmósfera además de las repercusiones
nocivas y duraderas para el desarrollo
sostenible y los ecosistemas la
acidificación de los océanos ha causado
que el ph de los mares esté en su nivel
más bajo en los últimos 26.000 años y el
nivel medio del mar a escala mundial
alcanzó nuevos máximos la onu pidió
reducir urgentemente el uso de
combustibles fósiles pero pareciera pues
que esta idea cada vez se va alejando
más más y más y para ello entonces
quiero saludar a nuestro segundo
invitado del día
johnny martínez representante de la
organización meteorológica mundial para
norteamérica centroamérica y el caribe
gracias running por estar con nosotros
en directo américa de france 24 muy buen
día le pregunta entonces los índices
se preocupan
buenos días muchas gracias por la
entrevista y la oportunidad de difundir
este mensaje que creemos es crítico para
la humanidad del desarrollo sostenible
definitivamente los datos reportados en
el reporte en el que se pueden lanzar
hasta el día de hoy indican claramente
que la temperatura global media se sigue
su paso muy firme de ascenso reportamos
en este el durante el 2021 una anomalía
de 1.11 grados centígrados por encima de
lo normal en relación al período
preindustrial es decir es en comparación
al período en 1850 1900 sobre el cual se
basan todos los acuerdos sobre cambio
climático el acuerdo de parís y la meta
al no alcanzar el
1.5 grados centígrados hasta el 2030
vamos cada vez aproximándonos a esa a
esa meta o ese límite que no debemos
pasar por los riesgos que conlleva para
el sistema planetario el año 2021 tuvo
una ligera modulación una una ligera
mitigación asociada al episodio la niña
que dominó en el pacífico
pero eso no ha quitado la tendencia
ascendente de la temperatura del mar del
medio en general claro también hablabas
de estos acuerdos de parís también vimos
el de glasgow o acuerdos y cumbres
digamos que pareciera que se quedaran en
el papel y nos fascina al respecto
porque no se están tomando las medidas
necesarias porque los gobiernos
realmente no accionan frente al clima
nuestro planeta que realmente sin pues
planeta no hay vida
pues sí yo creo que esa es la gran
pregunta que tenemos todos la ciencia
cada vez confirma y confirma con más
contundencia todo lo que está sucediendo
el efecto directo de la acción
antropogénica de la acción de la
humanidad sobre el sistema terrestre y
esto no surge definitivamente a como
sociedad a demandar más decisiones de
parte de los gobiernos porque de lo
contrario esta crisis planetaria pues va
acelerándose e independientemente todos
los problemas sociales económicos
conflictos que se viven el tema de
cuidar el planeta la casa donde vivimos
es fundamental y para ello la ciencia
también sugiere claros caminos de cómo
remediar la y el tema del cambio de
energía en la matriz energética y
volcarnos a energías limpias de energías
alternativas es una solución ya dejar
los combustibles fósiles por un tema de
subsistencia por un tema de
sostenibilidad
definitivamente debemos preocuparnos por
un futuro que cada vez se ve más
incierto
claro ni también yo le quería preguntar
entonces al día de hoy estamos muy tarde
para comenzar una acción dramática
contundente
yo creo que todavía tenemos tiempo pero
cada vez el planeta nos va dando señales
muy duras muy contundentes de que el
cambio climático está afectando ya todo
el equilibrio planetario en cada vez y
el 2021 no es la excepción los eventos
extremos alrededor de todo el planeta
tanto por sequías extremas tanto por
eventos de lluvia o precipitación
extremos están afectando la vida están
afectando el desarrollo están afectando
la economía la la pérdida de vidas
humanas y todos estos eventos tienden a
ser récords inéditos
tuvimos una ola de calor
muy intensa durante los bienes tienen
varios sitios del planeta donde se
alcanzaron récords históricos tuvimos y
por eso el nivel del mar por ejemplo se
está incrementando claro porque ha
habido tanto deshielo de sitios
glaciares alrededor del mundo por olas
de calor que han sido inéditas que han
sobrepasado a los 49 50 grados
centígrados y con la consiguiente
pérdida de vidas humanas entonces el
planeta nos está indicando cada vez con
más
con más fuerza todas las alteraciones
que estamos generando y lo que no
queremos es que el sistema planetario
llegue a un punto de no retorno en donde
no podemos decir qué puede pasar después
de ello ese tippingpoint de ese punto
crítico de no retorno es el que debemos
preservar queremos precautelar y tomar
definitivamente en serio el tema de
cambio climático porque hay mucha
discusión está en la agenda política
pero eso se tiene que traducir en
acciones hablabas también ronnie de este
aumento de las temperaturas de las olas
de calor del año pasado y ya estamos a
mayo también lo estábamos registrando
precisamente hoy en nuestras noticias de
directo américa que hay olas de calor ya
también en españa en francia digamos en
europa y en otros países de asia eso
también se va incrementando a medida que
pasan pues los días y que no se hace
nada respecto al clima también hablamos
del derretimiento de los pueblos esto en
consecuencia aumenta el nivel del mar
del mar las olas de calor que
pronósticos podemos esperar para lo que
nos queda de este año podemos ver con
más agresividad estos cambios de clima
estos fenómenos climáticos
bueno tenemos el año por delante se nos
viene la temporada de huracán el señor
en el caribe los pronósticos iniciales
las estimaciones sobre esta temporada
huracanes es que va a ser una temporada
con mayor frecuencia de tormentas y
sistemas tropicales fuertes entonces
yo creo que el pronóstico es que este
tipo de eventos se sigan manifestando la
frecuencia de eventos estemos en
distintas partes del planeta más lo que
ya tenemos en este momento
como consecuencia de ello por ejemplo la
hambruna la amenaza a la seguridad
alimentario en varias partes del planeta
y que está agravada para además por
condiciones externas que no tienen que
ver con finalmente con el sistema
climático pero que también están
sumándose en el conflicto internacional
en este momento la cadena de suministro
etcétera está haciendo que cada vez
millones de personas experiente
experimenten el hambre y además estén en
una fragilidad muy grande respecto a su
seguridad alimentaria futuro y su
seguridad hídrica porque el tema de las
sequías cada vez va tocando más
continentes y más áreas